[Music]
this wait we've got an [ __ ] driver
Photoshop fail and another deadly
challenge why did they make this
recorder shaped like a dick what does it
remind you of
oh it's ergonomically designed for your
mouth Oh a flute
alright over first story we have this
guy in New York in Times Square
he ended up peeling out in Times Square
there's this cop that tried stopping him
Ryan right in front of his car and the
dude pretty much almost ran over the
police officer I have a video who I want
to see this I've been a time school no
[Applause]
that is not a peel that's the closest
year yet that's the [ __ ] telephone it
squeaky old door [ __ ] everyone's like
better right I hope with Apple door I
should have open yeah alright here's the
video
Wow he's so cool look at that Wow gotta
buy new tires wow what a cool guy
oh they are they're all modern up cars
oh no no no oh shoot at him is he
allowed to shoot at him dude that person
could go to jail for like ever
that is [ __ ] up that's like a sour
with a deadly weapon what what ethnicity
is easy Chinese but didn't have a
license plate
so apparently initially they couldn't
find out who were the drivers really who
was in the car and so they were even
asking the public to see if they could
call in for any tips they finally
brought in two men as suspects for
questioning so we don't know if it is
those guys or not because it hasn't been
completely confirmed but why do guys
dude don't oh that was not what I
thought I thought it was a Chinese kid
why cause black people can't have
Mercedes's cuz that Mercedes look really
gaudy as [ __ ] so I thought it was a
Chinese person that's true is it Korean
or Chinese people they loved Mercedes
yeah yeah
Mercedes engine and he hooked it up like
a rice rocket - how come the dollar left
this checking out a girl I can't be sure
take it can I see the car again Vidya I
think there's evidence I can find that
other people can't find there's a
[ __ ] license plate on that car man oh
you can't make it out at all like no
matter how hard you ever recorded that
video you [ __ ] suck for having a
shitty phone well you know the guy that
recorded this is actually pretty
impressive cuz he's he's a skateboarder
so this whole time he was skateboarding
in the midst of all that cuz this videos
a lot longer and so like you could see
the cop chasing the car and then this
skateboarders what happens we don't
throw all the cars trying to get a high
phone ex this case you nice stuff hey
you beat me what that was gonna say that
cave unites it he always has that what
is that booze board yeah
Wow skaters name is Kiefer Dixon how old
were the two I'm not sure they don't if
they were like 19 I think it's okay it's
it's okay oh you know what it's the
first one the one on the left he's 20
the other one he looks it's okay you
know why I would have done the same
really your brain not maybe not in New
York because it's stupid wow what an
hour done I would have done something
stupid I would have never done that in a
pack Street though it was always at an
open parking lot it was at night when
there was nobody there
it's you're responsible oh you're still
dumb but you're responsible thank you
mm-hmm we did that in a parking lot when
I was like 18 or 19
things like the parking lot though yeah
and then when the cop came like all of
us left but then he targeted my friend
so my friend had a stop you legit try to
kill a cop I can't believe you trying to
run the cop over that's [ __ ] balls
that do should be a joke forever that's
the part where I won't say it's okay but
the peel that part that's not okay it's
not okay but you're 19 you're not mean
like you're just gonna do irresponsible
[ __ ] like that full right there but then
they're running over the cop and try not
get away that's not that's not I
guarantee you that fool has like some
priors that because yeah there's no
reason for him that you know what I mean
cuz he would have just got a ticket for
like reckless driving or some [ __ ]
now you just increased your sentences
yeah and then there's video proof of it
too I would have just been like oh yeah
I [ __ ] up give me the ticket that
Hotel lucky that that cop was like just
a regular ass cop and he looked kind of
scared yeah it was like some SWAT
[ __ ] he's like holding on to
that Daniel just pulled the gun on his
blasting through the windshield cuz I
tried to kill him yeah cuz sometimes
SWAT SWAT cops they still have to do
patrol every now and then just to cut
like cover or whatever and then he's
right he's got lucky there's just like a
regular ass dude that was just oh [ __ ]
I'm kind of scared at this moment I kind
of want to see those situations like in
the movies like if that happened it was
a SWAT cop guy tries to run he jumps on
the hood and just goes ba ba ba ba ba
and you see the car just slowly just
coast into another car I don't have a
good time
and he walks off like a movie alright so
for our next story which is my favorite
one out of these three
there was this professional photographer
that was hired for a family portrait
session
oh I saw this one
so the person that hired this
photographer posts it up these photos
that the photographer turned in and she
said in her post she said okay this is
not a joke we paid a photographer who
claimed to be a professional to $250 for
a family photo shoot please see these
for real photos she delivered to us
she said the shadows were really bad on
the beautiful clear sunny day and that
her professor never taught her how to
retouch photos oh no feel free to share
and hold it to laughing emoji you gotta
see this I literally have not laughed
this hard in years you can't make this
stuff up again this is not a joke final
product I want to hire this person
though what the [ __ ] can you even see
their faces it's no no it's it's scary
like it's bad I think it's worse on the
kid that's skillful like how do you make
those faces
did you just copy and get it it looks
like it looks like white people doing
like white face I don't even know how I
wish the dogs were touched by what I saw
this I was like in tears can you make
the face like big as [ __ ]
they look like video games oh this
person should specialize in this [ __ ] my
god he's actually really good in a
really bad way
what because that should take skill cuz
I can't do that [ __ ] no I actually tried
fighting like previous work of this
photographer I couldn't find anything
cuz her Facebook page went down god damn
what's wrong with their eye like they
thought this was okay to release like
they thought this was okay to give as a
finished product
yeah well it's because so this is what
happens
they're shooting this at height daytime
right Sun is at the highest peak is it
blown out no that's really harsh shadows
on all so it's just all over like crazy
contrast a lot of contrast a lot of dark
circles under their eyes because if the
Sun is as high as possible it creates
like dark shadows on your face so he's
trying to like add a lot of clarity so
he could wipe all that [ __ ] out are you
backing up the face and this is how you
get this melted monster where he drew it
on she yeah she had it wrong with it
wrinkles yeah yes hello what I was
trying to find previous work I came
across these videos this video is
someone trying to do a tutorial of how
to get faces like I feel like this will
actually spend a lot of time on the
photos though is fine she-she-she
sorry I watch that tutorial and what
they did is they blurred out the entire
face yeah and then they'd manually drew
over the eyes and the face like damn why
do they look like demon geisha and [ __ ]
okay I want to hire this person she's
she's awesome you don't have to you
could just uh give her one of your old
photos and I just have her touch it up
she could start a business doing this
it's much scary you know and I saw
something I gotta talk about this with
you guys know hold when I saw it it kind
of it felt kind of weird like creepy
yeah it felt like it was gonna be a
horror like movie or something
I can see this blown up and put out an
art show though and the people would
actually probably oh yeah yeah yeah so
different what
[ __ ] is wrong with art like have you
guys ever been to like Melrose or just
anywhere that has Contemporary Art
Road other than that this sucks let's
just say that they have art there I
literally did a whole video where I just
made fun of the whole place which I
found I felt a little bad after yeah but
at the same time there was a picture of
five charcoal dicks that were drawn on a
piece of paper and I was worth millions
of dollars yeah I did that in high
school and I was sent out to the
principal's office I feel like that kind
of art I think it's a big [ __ ] joke
it has to be a giant it's I think it's
one of those things where you know like
the that that story of the King with the
invisible clothes yeah so I think it's a
racket to [ __ ] with rich people because
rich people don't know what's in because
they're they lost touch with the regular
world right so all these artists they
come out here and they make some weird
[ __ ] [ __ ] and then people want to be
cool rich people want to buy this [ __ ]
and then within their circle of friends
it's like oh you've got that piece I
want that piece too I think it's a big
[ __ ] has to be damned yeah
it's literally you take one of those
little charcoal blocks and you do this
you draw a dick like this that's
literally what
that's literally what is not even I'm
not exaggerating I'm actually probably
doing a better job making fun of it
right now than it actually is drawn and
it's worth like millions Wow
oh I get so frustrated over that because
like it's nothing
it doesn't take years to do even some of
the abstract artists like when like back
in it and I guess like in the 90s or
whatever's Picasso there's still some
sort of like structure behind it like a
level of skill there's yeah yeah there's
levels of skill but these guys aren't
even like worthy of being called
abstract or it's kind of like this is my
pace she's at basketball in the hallway
on the door I just type so then the
weight of the describe it is oh like the
amount of emotion and anger that you
through that napkin down that's art like
it captured that well can I just like
[ __ ] bust your teeth in and leave
your teeth on the floor and call it art
yeah although it's not a crime scene
let's do that it's art yeah but the
weird thing is like that's everyday
expression that's not even like
exaggerated or told in a interesting way
when you walk in I just feel like I want
to
like that's contemporary art like every
single piece makes me feel like I'm
gonna get a headache and I'm gonna
[ __ ] puke all over the floor and that
to me isn't it has to have range it has
to have like different types of it has
to get you you in the feelers from like
calmness to love to whatever but as soon
as I walk in it's like [ __ ] you [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] that's all i feel
like i think that's what makes me like
whenever I look just like at a white
canvas that somebody just put white
paint on it I'm just like why why it's
wrong ah it just makes you so fortunate
but then the part of like the reason
that abstract art works is because like
they just want people to talk about it
whether you're how annoying it is yeah
like it's it's working in that sense I
hate contemporary art dude it's like the
laziest [ __ ] art ever I I know that
this this kid was trying some [ __ ] and
selling his like canvas spans for like
2,000 bucks dude and it looked like
[ __ ] animal crackers like drawn
really shitty and I'm just like man this
is some [ __ ] do this but this is
different
I'm having artists starting tomorrow I'm
spitting on a piece of paper and I'm
putting it on my wall don't forget to
sign at the bottom I'll call it the
French slap last story have you guys
heard of the tide pot challenge yes I
did
I didn't know what that was realize
there we go that was a joke what
challenge the Thai hide pod you know the
washing pots oh yeah they just put it on
another now there's what half of them
are obviously joking yeah if they're not
seriously ingesting detergent but then
there's a really huge chunk of the other
half that they're actually taking this
for real and they're putting these the
charge in the mouth yeah I always
wondered what the warning like who the
warning label is for for them so the
natural selection [ __ ] that's
stupid to have to like hey you shouldn't
consume this shampoo I'm like really
that's why I think I think they should
take all the warnings off of things and
just let natural selection happen yeah
this is obviously one of the people
joking like they're not clearly it does
look delicious though type odds look
like candy I thought like do you have
eyes in your head like come on like it
does not look good at all like you could
see the powder you can see you think
that because you know it's so imagine if
it was like an ice cream oh oh yeah like
a jello or whatever well like if you
could put that in the freezer I guess if
you're only looking at the gel part I
could see that but like right behind it
it's like all the powder and like that I
don't look closely what the powder you
can think of it as like the fun dip
powder yeah no girl don't think of it at
all of candy just don't eat this but I
don't eat this they're already been
which makes reported deaths because of
it people are dying a lot so but see
this is what I'm saying I'm happy
they're good no and then most of them
are kids aged 13 to 19 exactly no way to
all three year old making videos
actually it's yeah it's sad if it's a
three year old but 13 to 19 then you
deserve to kind of die
so what's the real challenge like Church
you didn't put it in your mouth and I
will rephrase this I feel sorry for the
parents who have lost their kids but
your kids are [ __ ] dumb as [ __ ] yeah
this this girl survived I don't know who
this is just like all the tumor last
year they created a whole video yeah so
good like they're actually like going in
on it so then oh now it's gotten to the
point where tied themselves have gone
out oh my god advertisement saying like
hey we're not everything we don't even
need to do that that's the thing that's
crazy
hey guys don't eat the Tide Pods look
even what I love is doing like what is
it called
like dabbing or something like when you
smoke at her I don't know he's smoking
the freaking was not a terrible idea
yeah and so people are like they
shouldn't have made it so delicious
looking isn't it laundry detergent has a
lot of poison in it do not ingest it
don't even get on there even saying like
give it it could here
this is not this is just a six people is
a core issue of people who don't
understand they they just want social
currency yeah I mean so they just want
to be known for absolutely anything and
this is this is I I thought about this
too recently like as the worse and worse
this gets there's gonna be so much
censorship because of [ __ ] like this you
know it man YouTube's already announced
that they're taking down anything that
has to do with type odd challenge and
then now tide is like working with
different social media platforms to make
sure that they remove content to not
distribute like that sucks cuz they
don't even need to do that like a
mousetrap company doesn't need to come
out and say don't put this on your dick
but there's no no one needs to do
anything like that if you're [ __ ]
dumb enough to like put raid in your
cereal then just die it's it's kind of
interesting making it say like hey guys
you want to do the mercury shake
challenge let's [ __ ] it breaker or
thermometers and put the mercury inside
the [ __ ] shake yeah yeah it's just a
really odd world that we live in now
like anybody wants to be famous for just
about anything but even like some of
these you know when the six-second vine
thing happened they were still making
content that was you know relatively
funny for that moment you don't mean
they're still talent in that this is
talentless his [ __ ] the [ __ ] radiator
foolin challenge guys come on it's just
crazy dude that's so sad
[Music]